In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for June 19th, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Job, first patriarch of Moscow.
St. Job was born in about 1530 into a devout family of merchants in Stadecy near Tivir.
He received his earliest education in the town's monastery, in which he became a monk.
During long years he showed an exemplary life and was particularly distinguished by his
piety and his ability to recite many prayers and scriptural texts by heart.
Becoming Abbott, he was later called to Moscow to direct the Simonov monastery and then to
the Novosposki.
It was in this capacity that he took part in the Councils of the Russian Church, especially
one that produced statutes concerning monastic properties in 1580.
With reference to this, the saint spent his whole life in the strictest deprivation, giving
generously to the needy, and at his death they found only fifteen rubles and some clothing
and a few icons in his cell.
Consecrated Bishop of Kalomna, he was transferred five years later to Rostov and on the 11th of
December in 1587 was made metropolitan of Moscow.
From 1580, as the sovereign had received the title of Tsar and Russia had come to the aid
of the Christian Empire, the project of giving the Russian Church a patriarch was being considered.
The patriarch of Constantinople, Jeremiah II, went to Moscow in 1588, and at the end of
negotiations led by Boris Gedunov, Tsar Theodor Ivanovich announced that the Church of Constantinople
had given its consent to the establishment of the Russian Patriarchate of Moscow.
The Council of the Russian Church presented three candidates to the Tsar, who chose Saint
Job.
At his enthronement, which was celebrated on the 26th of January in 1589, Patriarch Jeremiah
raising the gospel over Job's head, prayed that he would become an inextinguishable
luminary of the faith, and they then celebrated the divine liturgy together.
Shortly afterwards, Saint Job elevated the four bishops of Novgorod, Kazan, Rostov, and
Sarai, to the rank of metropolitan, and in the large towns created arch-priests, having
responsibility for forty parishes.
In spite of numerous difficulties and the lack of teachers, he tried to organize education,
correcting the liturgical books and having them printed for the first time, and this in
a period of famine.
In Siberia and the territories of the Far East, which had recently been annexed to Russia,
the Patriarch organized monasteries with a missionary vocation, and many of the local
people asked for baptism.
Thus, the Christianization of Siberia could be attributed to Saint Job.
He founded more than ten monasteries, and each year of his Patriarchate was marked by the
founding of a new church in Moscow.
He also worked especially for the veneration of the Russian Saints, continuing the work
of St. Macadios of Moscow.
On the death of Tsar Theodor in 1598, Saint Job gave his support to the elevation to the
throne of Boris Gedanov, the brother of Empress Irina, who had renounced the throne in order
to enter a monastery.
The Patriarch did all that he could to reunite the principalities of the southeast that had
seceded under the rule of the false Dmitri.
On Boris's death, in 1605, the imposter seized the throne of Moscow and demanded the deposition
of the Holy Hierarch.
When the gates of Moscow were opened to the renegade, the Patriarch was accused of having
poisoned Tsar's John IV and Theodor I.
From the height of the Ambon, Saint Job denounced the false Dmitri and the real regicides.
Crushed by the wretched state of Russia, he spent his time in prayer in the cathedral of
the Dormition.
One day, when he was celebrating the Divine Liturgy, some of the false Dmitri's men of
arms rushed into the cathedral.
They jostled the saint, pulling him away from the altar and tearing his vestments.
Saint Job dispersed them and took refuge by the icon of the Mother of God of Vladimir and
putting on the Encolpion, Banaya, that he had received 19 years earlier from the ecumenical
Patriarch, he appealed to the all-holy to safeguard Orthodoxy.
The insurgents seized the old man, dragged him ignominiously through the streets, and then
exiled him, clad in a simple black habit to the monastery of Stadetsi, where he had received
monastic profession.
The rebels attempted to force his agreement to the installation of Archbishop Ignatius
of Risan in his place, but he flatly refused to give consent in this way.
After the false Dmitri was deposed and Tsar Basil was crowned, the Russian bishops gathered
in council, asked Saint Job to return to his sea, but the holy hierarchy, having become
blind, gave his blessing for Saint Edmoyenis to take the succession.
The troubles were by no means over, aggravated as they were by the intrigues of the Poles and
quarrels among the Russian princes, Patriarch Edmoyenis and Tsar, desiring to give the people
a chance to repent, asked Job to go to Moscow, arriving in the capital on the 14th of February
in 1607, the holy man stood before the people, clothed as a simple monk, and gave everyone
his absolution for the grave sin that they had committed against him, and for having broken
the vow of allegiance that they had made to their legitimate sovereign.
Having returned to the monastery of Stadetsi, he gave his soul into God's hands in peace
or months later, on the 19th of June in 1607.
When his relics were exhumed in 1652 to be translated to Moscow and placed in the cathedral
of the Dormition, they gave off a heavenly fragrance and became a source of healing.
After the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.